mein team hat sie sehr groß aus hallo
leute ich es wieder einmal wanne und
willkommen aus meiner küche lange ist es
her und deswegen freue mich umso mehr
dass ich heute kochen kann ihr habt den
titel schon gelesen ich mache heute das
perfekte römische den ungefähr zwei
jahren habe ich schon mal polnisch
gekocht und da habe ich mir eingeladen
denn ich habe klassische polnische
gerichte gemacht ohne fleisch dafür mit
fleisch ersatz und das habe ich arthur
nicht erzählt dann gab es die große
überraschung
heute wieder zum essen eingeladen was
aber nicht weiß ist dass ich versuche
nur polnisch mit ihm zu sprechen und das
bringt uns schon zum heutigen
kooperationspartner für dieses video
habe ist eine sprach lern app mit der du
bist zu 14 sprachen mittlerweile lernen
kannst und das nicht mit stumpfen
vokabeln auswendig lernen sondern mit
grammatik schreiben also du formuliert
am ende wirklich setzte die dich dann im
alltag oder auf reisen weiterbringen
können ich habe mir vor einigen wochen
war runter geladen um eine polnisch
kenntnisse aufzufrischen denn ich möchte
in ein paar wochen nach polen fahren
[Musik]
wird sowohl für zur begrüßung als auch
zum abschied verwendet das informellen
benutzen wenn du jemanden
doppel und das beste ist kino verliert
auch gerade angesprochen komplett neu zu
lernen
was stufe zu erreichen dass ich jetzt an
diesem wird ja also ob die jetzt ein
einsteiger bist oder schon sich mit der
sprache aus kenn das funktioniert für
beide seiten es gibt viele verschiedene
funktionen
lektionen untaten diese sprache dort zu
lernen und ich bin mittlerweile wieder
so gut dass ich mein bruder in polen
angerufen habe und mit ihm fließend
polnisch gesprochen habe und er wirklich
sehr überrascht war die lektion von über
150 sprachexperten entwickelt und
daneben gibt es aber auch noch podcast
oder spiele und wenn euch das zu
unpersönlich ist dann gibt es sogar noch
live session also für jeden was dabei
die lektionen dauern bis zu zehn minuten
und ja die zeit hat man und falls jetzt
auch so religiös auf opel bekommen habt
dann findet ihr in der infobox einen
link über den bekommt dir 30 prozent auf
den sechs monate zugang 1200 zugang und
den lifetime access also wenn das ist
ein tolles angebot ist weiß ich auch
nicht jetzt geht weiter mit dem video
podcast pavel kostal
wo sie sitzen
kinder will wie danke sagen du kannst
die augenbinde abnehmen was aber nicht
weiß ist dass ich versuche nur polnisch
mit ihm zu sprechen
und willkommen beim perfekten kunden
[Musik]
nur polnisch mit ihm zu sprechen
das ist unser wunderschöner tische heute
abend weil es echt schick wie findest du
das perfekte polen denn es ist eine
sache die auf tier so zwischen uns
passiert ja jetzt auch glauben bekennt
ist das kann dann nicht kannte oder
kannst du auch einen live kosten für
meinen kanal ja der jetzt wieder da ist
manchmal sehr da war ich kurz werbung
machen ja mache ja hallo kommt doch
vorbei auf einem kanal ja was gibt es da
verschiedene gamer
kochen
vielleicht schreiben reallife spannende
story geht ja mal auf seinen kanal
erfindet sondern wahrscheinlich in der
video beschreibung vielleicht und das
haus mit dem video till wöstmann
letztlich angeschrieben hat habe ich
mich schon sehr gefreut denn das letzte
mal als sie mich zu dem dreh eingeladen
hat muss sich auch der so viel essen und
das sehr sehr gut
und ja ich kenne den weg
mir geht es ganz gut ich wollte erst ein
fahrrad fahren aber dann fiel mir ein
ich fahr
ich kenne nicht langsam fahren also das
letzte mal ich bin letzten zu meiner
schwester dem fahrrad gefahren sind
stück weit raus und ich bin schon sehr
langsam gefahren
aber trotzdem schwitze ich immer so ein
bisschen
und ich wollte ja jetzt nicht
doch ich wusste das zu schwimmen aber
ich wusste zum beispiel nicht dass total
eine gute idee gewesen wäre dich
händlern zusätzlichen damals auch gut
und fliege aussehen ich bin wieder auf
eine hochzeit kann es mir helfen machte
ein video mit mir
das ist unser
später
wir
wären ja
ich muss arbeiten heute hast du ganz
deutlich gemacht werden wir jetzt hier
schon so sitzen sagen wir doch mal ein
bisschen unser polnisch auffrischen
[Gelächter]
wie der let's
dance
club wie dallas
wo ich weiß was
kannst du bereit für die vorspeise ich
bin so krass gespannt hat so jetzt
richtig gekocht
hat
japanisch polnisch mit vorspeise
hauptspeise und nach der schweiz auch
nur
fisch in gelee
galeristen
ist
das schön so was man gegessen ich glaube
jetzt kennt macht dich das nicht ich
auch nicht ich überhaupt nicht aber
später habe ich das schon wissen es zu
schätzen gewusst wobei es also wir essen
heute nicht vegan
wird zudem einen drauf ich dachte
wow
jetzt musst du mich fragen
[Musik]
wie hast du das denn zubereitet aber
barnetta wie hast du das hinzugerechnet
ganz einfach arthur wir beginnen mit dem
suppengrün dafür stehen wir die macht
hefti und den sellerie und befreien den
lauf vom dreck in den topf kommen noch
ein paar lorbeerblätter rein und dann
folgt das wort das gemüse wird so lange
gekocht bis ist weich wird in der
zwischenzeit kann man sich um die eier
kümmern und sie fest kochen in das
weiche gemüse springt noch ein räuber
hinein und darf bei schwacher hitze 15
minuten weiter ziehen die macht hefti
behalten wir und schneiden sie in
scheibchen danach schneiden wir den
rapper ein kleines stück oder pflücken
inhalt auseinander grüne wollen wir
beibehalten und sieben sie deshalb durch
auch durch ein tuch damit die gelatine
so klar wie möglich wird die gelatine
blätter werden in kaltes wasser
eingeweicht ungefähr fünf minuten dann
rühren wir sie in die warme brühe und
verrühren so lange bis sie sich
aufgelöst haben eier schälen und in der
mitte durchschneiden damit wir sie schön
präsentieren legen wir sie als erstes in
die silikon vor ich war wenn er eine
form für schoko aber da kann man
wirklich nehmen was man möchte und
danach kann sich mit petersilie mais
erbsen und den macht hälfte kreativ
ausgelebt werden zum ende kommt noch
eine große portion silber dazu und
schließen es mit mehr gemüse ab und dann
im kühlschrank nur noch darauf warten
dass die gelatine
festwirte zubereitung aber ein ganz
einfach
das merkt schnell dass man mit messer
kann es auch machen also viel zu spät
ich habe gerade erfolge bald ich wollte
es einfach mal einmal teilnahme gehe ich
weiß nicht ob ich mal
okay ist es nicht furchtbar salz da
es immer besser wenn man nach salz die
vorspeise war auf jeden fall ich nenne
es mal ein happening also diese diese
weise geld kamen wir mit dem ganzen
gemüse darin ziemlich abgefahren ja ja
das noch schön auf rechnung gibt's zum
nächsten teil okay
da das papier kränker wird zu sagen was
wir hier haben wie heißt es bereits
geheißen dass nochmals mit backpapier
[Musik]
kranke
was ich war mit meiner oma in polen
immer im stadion
ins stadion und auf dem rückweg wird
immer in so einem kleinen fenster vorbei
gegangen und der rasen so eine ältere
dame trainieren und dann kannst du dir
genau diese dinger besteht mit zu wissen
wie ich die zugeleitet haben ich würde
nicht gerne wissen wie es zubereitet
zunächst stellen wir eine tombola und
schneiden sie in der hälfte durch danach
in halbmonde schneiden und mit den
pilzen weitermachen champignons habe ich
vorher vom dreck befreit und schneide
sie erst in scheiben und dann in ganz
kleine stücke lassen sie sich später
besser auf dem parkett verteilen fun
fact als ich geschaut habe was die
krankheit wurde mir auflauf
vorgeschlagen also keine ahnung warum
dieses gerichts ab ihr kranker genannt
wird die erhitzen öl in einer pfanne und
geben die cebulla hinein schwitzen sie
gut an und danach kommen auch schon die
pilze die sollten so lange gebraten
werden bis die flüssigkeit aus ihnen
verdampft es würzen mit soll und caps
nicht vergessen dass vor gebackene
baguette halbieren und nach und nach die
pilz mischung darüber geben anschließend
den reibe käse in meinem fall gouda
darüber verteilen ab in den ofen damit
auf grillfunktion und obere schiene den
käse schmelzen lassen ausholen und ganz
wichtig mit viel ketchup verzieren
fertig und dazu gibt es polnisches bier
tom
hoopers in polen sind
also sagt ihr könnt es ja kein richtiges
hauptgericht sondern er soll streetfood
japanisches bietet aber ich dachte das
ist so lecker und so man hat damit so
eine gute verbindung ich wie gesagt eine
meiner eine meiner letzten sachen besten
sachen
rede
ich immer hier einfach wie man die ja
also die mich komplett verbindet mit
meiner kindheit das war nie meine jugend
zur kindheit das muss ich auch meine
mutter folgten die hauptspeise war auf
jeden fall mein haider es ist wirklich
ein traum eines jeden kindes wobei meine
oma der zu darum glaube ich jetzt gar
nicht so gerne gegessen hat sie hat uns
einfach nur gerne gegönnt ich würde
sagen wir es noch auf und dann kommt
jetzt der nachtisch und
zur nachspeise gibt es einen sally was
ist ein polnisches polnischer nachtisch
spannend nur den hingekriegt hat ich bin
auch gespannt weil es war wirklich so
ein rezept ist das hängt von meiner
mutter sein können
als sie dann die kosten am ende auf den
dingen gemacht
das ist meine mutter das kind ich noch
nicht so viel und dann haben wir mehr
spieler kennst du auch mit schokolade
schokolade
ich übertreibe mal so aber also leute
denken ich übertreibe es kommt aber aus
tiefsten herzen ich fühlte das ist auch
so ein paar meiner der von meinem bruder
oder meine oma der ist immer schon so
ein bisschen mit dem flop ich mag das
aber ganz gerne
für meine mutter
[Musik]
also zuerst er schmeckt wie bei den
kubanern jetzt habe ich jetzt reagieren
wenn ich gleichzeitig zweitens kokos
kommt geil
die konsistent ist genau richtig wer sie
gemacht dass umfragen ganz genau zuerst
trennen wir die ica in dem rezept
welches ich gefunden habe sind es acht
stück das kommt mir ein bisschen viel
vor aber das video hat über zwei
millionen aufrufe also vertrauen wir dem
prozess das eiweiß wird mit einer prise
salz aufgeschlagen einmal testen ob es
steif ist perfekt in eine sehr große
schüssel geben wir ein glas zucker ja
ein glas keine genauere anweisung dazu
noch die eigelbe und mixen bis die masse
viel heller geworden ist die weiche
masse dazu geben und wieder kurz mix
dann folgen eineinhalb gläser milch und
passt bitte auf das eure milch nicht zu
kaltes ihm eine denn sonst wird die
butter wieder h im original video
benutzt sie einen eimer auf dem truck
steht das übersetzt hüttenkäse heißt das
aber ganz genau so wie frischkäse
aussieht nehmen wir einfach mal den ein
kilogramm ja ich weiß dass es ganz schön
viel die masse wird wieder verrühren
sieht auch wieder cremig aus wir können
aufhören wegen der kalten weg zu weinen
drei packungen vanillepudding oder wie
es auf polnisch heißt wenn new york
buden sorry aber buden klingt so lustig
ja ja die kommen auf jeden fall rein und
ihr könnt es euch denken gehören noch
mal das war aber auch das letzte mal
jetzt wird der schnee vorsichtig
untergehoben wir nehmen uns eine
backform legen sie mit backpapier aus
und streichen ein wenig rest butter auf
die seite und mit einem keks eurer wahl
den bodenbelägen die damen herbert niki
was glaube ich den kaffee keks am
nächsten kommt aber ich liebe die bis
kopf kekse also lasst mich vorsichtig
gießen wir die masse auf die ordentlich
angeordneten kekse und streichen die
oberfläche glatt und für den extra kick
scake legen wir noch kekse im rand aus
ich konnte ehrlich gesagt nicht
herausfinden welche ofen einstellungen
sie vorgehen 160° funktion
objekt habe ich noch nie gehört also
habe ich meinen bruder in polen
angerufen und er versicherte mir dass
160 bis 170 grad umluft sind was ich
aber bis heute nicht glauben kann aber
egal wie ihr seht ist eher was geworden
und nachdem er vollständig ausgekühlt
ist setzen wir uns in einem topf mit
heißem wasser haltige fed glasuren
gießen diese dann über den kuchen ein
bisschen verstreichen kokosraspeln
drüber merken dass die kokosraspeln
einsinken die glasur kurz an herten
lassen und dann auf einer zu harten
glasur die kokosraspeln erneut
drüberstreuen fertig das mega können den
massenproduktion für einen von kokos
zeug aber hier ist es ja meist also dass
man zusammen kleinbauern die darauf
geschnitten hätten besser ich mag anbau
und tischt gut
die nachspeise einfach der haben also
ihr mitwirken sollen den kann man sehr
sehr einfach verpacken und ich denke
wenn der tee macht jetzt auch nicht so
häufig in ihrem leben also da wo die
sagen exquisite backhus unglaublichkeit
und dann auch noch immer der schokolade
zusammenhang macht man das denn kein
mehl drei packungen von einem komplott
naja schlafen kannst
anker
lag butter
passwörter
manche wurde hat man halt immer an und
dann sagen wollten wir schaffen es nicht
hat man gesagt habe man ihr schaffen
das deutsche wort aber wieder voll
[Gelächter]
lustig dazu dass man stellen sich schon
bestimmte trigger würde
danach schaffen
[Musik]
monika neue costa rica das heißt auf dem
probieren will nicht gehen
[Musik]
ist es nicht so ganz
schlapp macht
auch noch punkte geben für das
eventuelle perfekt
und ich habe mir sehr viele gedanken
gemacht natürlich da gilt es ja einiges
zu beachten das ambiente die
unterhaltung und natürlich das essen und
dann hab ich mir überlegt ja da ja
ich liebe sagt koch
ein
[Musik]
sieg wäre mir
mir
irgendwas mit so bewirbt hat nico lange
ich dann eingeladen hat jimmy choo es
nach der fantastischen daniel
walter boltz kill
switch
schnell
[Musik]